what does ufo mean
it means it's uh a flying object
and it's not
identified
uh clearly at the time of sighting
that's what ufo means so it could be uh
physics phenomena it could be bald
lightning it could be all kinds of
fascinating i was always fascinated with
ball lightning as a
um
like the fact that there could be
physical phenomena in this world that
are observable by the human eye of
course all physical phenomena generally
are fascinating that are
that that really smart people can't
explain i love that because it's like
wait a minute especially if you can
replicate it
it's like wait a minute how does this
happen that's like the precursor to
giant discoveries in chemistry biology
and physics and so on but it sucks when
those events are super rare right
physical like like ball lightning
uh so
so that's out there and then
of course that phenomena could have
other interpretations that don't have to
do with the physics the chemistry the
biology of earth it could have to do
with more
extraterrestrial explanations
that
in large part
thanks to hollywood and movies and all
those kinds of things captivates the
imaginations of millions of people
uh but just because it's science fiction
that captivates the imagination of
people doesn't mean that some of those
sightings
all it takes is one
one of those sightings
is actually a sign that's it's
extraterrestrial intelligence that it's
um
object that's not of this particular
world do you think there's a chance that
that's the case what do you make
especially the pilot sightings what do
you make of those
um so i i agree there's a chance there's
always a chance any good scientist would
have to observation observationists
would have to
you know i want to see if aliens exist
come come to earth
what i know about the universe is i
think it's unlikely right now that there
are aliens visiting us
but but not impossible
i think the um releases the
dramatization
that's been happening politically saying
we're going to release all this
information this you know classified
information
um i was kind of disappointed because it
was just
very poor um
material
and
right now the the you know the the
ability to capture
high resolution video everybody is
carrying around with an incredible video
device now and
we haven't
got more compelling data
and so that we've just
seen
grainy pictures
a lot of hearsay
instrument kind of malfunctions and
whatnot and so i think on balance
i think it's extremely unlikely but i
think something really interesting is
happening
um
and also during the pandemic right we've
all been locked down we all want to have
we want to our imaginations are you know
running riot
and i think that the the i don't think
that the the information out there has
convinced me there are any anything
interesting on the ufo side but what it
has made me very interested about is how
humanity is opening up its mind to
ponder
aliens
and the the mystery of our universe and
so i don't want to dissuade people from
having those thoughts and say you're
stupid and look at that it's clearly
incorrect that's not right that's not
fair what i would say is that i lack
sufficient data replicated
observations to to make me go oh i'm
going to take this seriously
but i'm really interested by the fact
that there is this um
this great deal of interest and i think
that it it drives me
to maybe want to make or make an
artificial life form even more and to
help nasa
and the air force and whoever go and
look for things even more because i
think humanity wants to know what's out
there there's this yearning isn't there
yeah but but i
see i almost
uh depending on the day i sometimes
agree with you but uh
with the thing you just said
but one of the disappointing things to
me about the sightings
i still hold the belief that
a non-zero
number of them
uh
is an indication of something very
interesting
so i don't side with the people who say
everything can be explained with like uh
sensor artifacts kind of thing yeah i'd
agree with you i didn't say that either
i would say i just don't have enough
data right but the thing i want to push
back on is is the statement that
everybody has a high definition camera
one of the disappointing things to me
about like the report that the
government released but in general is
having worked with government having
worked
with people all over uh is how
incompetent we are
like if you look at the response to the
pandemic
how incompetent we are
in the face of great challenges
without great leadership
how incompetent we are in the face of
the great mysteries before us without
great leadership and i just think
it's actually the fact that there's a
lot of high definition cameras is not
enough
to capture
the full richness of weird
of the mysterious phenomena out there of
which extraterrestrial intelligence
visiting earth could be won i don't
think we have i don't think everybody
having a
smartphone in their pocket
is enough i think that allows for
tick-tock videos i don't think it allows
for
the capture of even interesting
relatively rare human events
that's not that common
it's rare to have be in the right moment
in the right time to be able to capture
the thing
i agree i agree let me let me rephrase
what i think on this i i haven't seen
enough information i haven't really
actively sought it out i must admit but
i'm i'm with you and i love the idea of
anomaly detection in chemistry in
particular right i want to make
anomalies sorry or not necessarily make
anomalies i want to
understand an anomaly let me give you
two from chemistry
um which are really quite interesting um
phlogiston going way back
where people said there's this thing
called phlogiston
and for ages the alchemists got really
um
this kind of the this the fire is the
thing
um and that's one and we determined that
logistics wasn't what we thought it is
let's go to physics the ether the if is
a hard one because i think actually the
ether might exist and i'll tell you what
i think the ether is later
um
and it and it
traveling through the ether in the
vacuum there is some thing that we call
the ether that that basically mediates
the the movement of light
say and i think that um and then the
other one is cold fusion which is more
so a few years ago
um that that people observed when they
did some electrochemistry when they were
splitting water into hydrogen and oxygen
that you got more energy out than you
put in and people got excited and they
thought that this was a nuclear reaction
and um and in the end it was kind of
discredited because you didn't detect
neutrons and all stuff but
i'm pretty sure
i'm a chemist i'm going telling you this
on your podcast but why not i'm pretty
sure there's interesting electrochemical
phenomena that's not completely bottomed
out yet that there is something there
however we lack the technology and the
experimental design
so all i'm saying in your response about
aliens is that we we lack the
experimental design to really capture
these anomalies
and we are in circulating encircling the
planet with many more detection systems
we've got satellites everywhere so there
is i do hope that we are going to
discover more anomalies and remember
that the solar system isn't just static
in space it's moving through the
universe
so there's just more and more chance i'm
not what with avi loeb that uh he's
generating all sorts of kind of
um
occult i would say uh with this but
there but i'm not against him i think
there is a finite chance if there are
aliens in the universe that we're going
to happen upon them because we're moving
through the universe
you